body and stunt doubles of the unsung
heroes of the movie industry putting
themselves on the line so actors getting
paid a lot more money get to look
awesome thanks to the magic of editing
stunt doubles don't have to look all
that much like the actor they're filling
in for but sometimes the production
needs someone with a strong physical
resemblance to a star who better to call
on than actors close relative these
films took advantage of shared DNA to
pull off some tricky seen leaving
audiences none the wiser Pirates of the
Caribbean on Stranger Tides in the
fourth installment of the Pirates of the
Caribbean franchise series leading lady
Keira Knightley was replaced by Penelope
Cruz who got some great news soon after
the filming of on Stranger Tides began I
am with child yours
the father is actually fellow Spanish
actor Javier Bardem the villain of the
film's follow up dead men tell no tales
the news put a kink in the production
plans considering her characters
introduced in a tricky three-minute
sword fighting scene her doctor was
likely deemed too risky sure she's
dressed up like Jack Sparrow I'm
Angelica
he'll check so they could have used any
old stunt double but Curtis younger
sister Monica approved to be a far
better match as a trained dancer with
sword fighting experience
Monica reportedly doubled for Penelope
during most of her fight scenes as well
as the number of full body shots later
in production to hide her sister's
burgeoning baby bump Forrest Gump Tom
Hanks didn't actually pound the pavement
the entire time they were filming those
cross-country running scenes and Forrest
Gump
his younger brother Jim filled in for
him for a few hundred yards shots in
Montana and South Carolina along with
bearing a strong physical resemblance to
his brother Jim's voice is virtually
identical to that of his famous sibling
there's no crying and voice mail which
has earned him gigs voicing sheriff
woody in Toy Story videogames
straight-to-dvd movies and more haha boy
am I glad to see you is that you now
it's my brother Jim Furious 7 after Paul
Walker's untimely death in 2013
midway through filming Furious 7 the
future of the entire Fast and the
Furious franchise was called into
question
production was temporarily halted while
the studio's sorted out options one of
which was using cgi to put his face onto
one of his two brothers Caleb and Cody
and have them film the rest of his scene
with the exception of a few CGI shots
deconstructed to show the process used
to revive him for the role the studio
hasn't revealed which seams are real and
which are fake but about 350 overall
shots had to be altered the end result
is a film where it's near impossible to
tell exactly when you're looking at Paul
Walker repurposed footage spliced into
the scene his face CGI onto one of his
brothers bodies or even a combination of
all three most of the rocks-- movies
Dwayne the rock Johnson is a physically
massive human being so there aren't too
many stuntmen who can convincingly
pretend to be him right well there is
one Ken oh I read who also happens to be
his cousin and also happens to be the
size of a refrigerator nothing you see
beautiful refrigerator
very wise as one of the few human beings
with arms equal in size to his cousin
breed has been working as his stunt
double for virtually his entire acting
career in fact
Rena's doubled for his cousin for so
long he appeared in the films that still
credited Dwayne as the rock the ones in
which he started as Dwayne the rock
Johnson and of course the more recent
blockbusters crediting him as simply
Dwayne Johnson including the Baywatch
reboot who only he can help me some
other time thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel plus check all this cool stuff
we know you love to
[Music]